Let's walk through all the choices I gave you,
and try to understand which can be categorized as an
abstraction, and which is not an abstraction. Door knob
is something that we use all the time to enter
a room, when you open a door. And that's
an abstraction because we don't know how the door knob
may actually be implemented, nor do we care. So that's
an abstraction. Instruction set architecture of a processor is once
again an abstraction, because it tells you what
the processor's capable of doing, not how it is
doing it. Now the third choice I'm giving you
here, is the number of pins coming out of
a chip. Now, this is being very specific
as to, what exactly is going on here? That
these are exactly the number of pins coming out
of a chip, and therefore it's not an abstraction.
The next choice is an and logic gate,
again here it's only saying what the function of
the logic gate is, not how it is
doing it. And therefore, this is an abstraction. The
next choice is transistor, and this again, is
an abstraction, because we don't know how exactly the
transistor is implemented. All we know is a
functionality of the transistor. For instance, if a transistor
is used as a switching device, you know
that using the transistor you can turn it on
and off, but you don't know what exactly is
going on under the covers in order to make
that work in the solid state physics. The next
choice is INT data type. Now, again it's only
saying that it is a data type and the
name is INT. And therefore you can use this
as a data type that holds integers in your program, but it doesn't tell you how
the data type is actually implemented by the compiler and therefore INT datatype
is also an abstraction. The last choice is saying the exact location of base
pads in baseball field. Again, this one
is being very specific about some particular feature,
namely, base pads and how they're laid out in
a baseball field and therefore, this is not an abstraction.